[Music]
hey you guys
holy crap yeah we went out last night
i'm so tired
so i went to see the loan officer
and uh everything looked good
i'll own the place in about three months
well you know not outright we'll just
not all right
yeah we'll be paying for it i'm gonna
give you the money the um which i was i
was kind of surprised i was kind of like
i don't think he's going to give it to
me
[Laughter]
that's a lot of money
but um
i did have some [ __ ] i had to take care
of first man i owed somebody didn't even
know i owed somebody a thousand bucks
they were trying to collect on me about
a thousand
and it's from 2016 and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is that
and the only thing i haven't called them
to see who it is but the only thing i'm
thinking was with the time beijing put
me in the hospital
yeah the va paid all that
which is good because you were in there
for like four days yeah
but something that they charged me for
something that the va didn't pay for
so i got paid yeah like i said some
doctor probably cruised by and it's like
hey what's up yeah cha-ching that's like
this is you feeling okay okay yeah thank
you
and then they were psychological
counseling and i was like what you know
psychological counseling he was like
[ __ ] up
but uh that's some [ __ ] right there
yeah because they do that [ __ ] to you
yeah i know and um
uh but it looks like they'll settle it
out anyway it's like probably throwing
500 and that'll go away yeah and
i gotta after all this time yeah they
clearly don't want it that bad because
they haven't been bothering you about it
and i gotta get my credit card totally
paid off three months in a row and my
credit score will go up a little bit
into like the very good level and
that will then it'll go through so i was
just going to do it it's got to bite the
bullet you know
well like i said you know this is a good
area to buy in i think
yeah the value will go up and if we
don't buy it soon then it's gonna be
where it's gonna be too much for us to
afford so yeah so we have to do it now
yeah um there is some leeway there they
could have given me a little bit more
okay so if it goes up a little bit over
the next three months i don't think
it'll go up over the next 90 days
because a neutral party has to come in
and appraise it and all that i don't
think it'll i don't think it'll go up
appreciably
it might go down because there are some
problems in here
yeah i mean some of this stuff like some
of these these doors are pretty damn
beat up and
there's some molding that's [ __ ]
broken and um
the uh
having problems with that dish that
dishwasher and the damn garbage disposal
we'll we'll see i don't know those are
mostly consumables maybe i don't know if
that has anything to do with the
appraisal
i don't think so generally
yeah i think they just check like kind
of the structure and i mean you know
obviously if it's like [ __ ]
uh david june said killer picks from
last night jen thank you
that i was like so
can i just say i was very impressed with
myself yeah well i'm good because yeah
and it's like and i didn't even i gave
myself like five hours like before we
left because i was like i know that i'm
gonna [ __ ] it up because i've never done
it before and i know i'm gonna [ __ ] it
up and i'm just gonna get pissed off i'm
gonna have to wipe it all off and start
over but i did not yeah i did it good
the first time jen's costume was uh she
went as a mexican
[Laughter]
she went as a mexican girl dressed for
[ __ ] dia de los wear those yeah and
it's she pulled it off it's just the
sugar skull thing pulled it off look
good
uh maddie p says did you move far from
your old place about 15 minutes 15 miles
yeah i think it's about 15 miles yeah
and i find it finding more out about
this area you know the downtown eustis
yeah in the next two years it's gonna be
totally rebuilt it's gonna be [ __ ] i
kind of figured because you can see even
in this neighborhood they're still
building new houses yeah across the
street around here they're building a
huge on the river it's gonna be kind of
like the one we just moved from which is
nice houses but they're a little close
together they're gonna pack a bunch of
them in over there
this place is more spread out yeah i
like that there's like the yards are
really really big big yards
and i'm gonna have to kill my uh
contract with the lawn guy which he's
from the 173 airborne i don't really
want to do it but it doesn't make sense
to have him come in here and mow this
for 150 a month when i can buy a ride on
loan mower and do myself
because i don't think he
i think he said he didn't do bushes so
if i could do those bushes i might as
well if you're gonna do the hedges you
might as well cut the grass yeah that
lawn mower will pay for itself in eight
months anyway
that's true so just gonna do it i mean
it is a big ass yard but
make sure that [ __ ] has headlights on
it so i can drive it at night
winter time you know you really only
have to do it maybe once or twice a
month once yeah it's really only summer
after summer mowing it every weekend
right you got to mow it every maybe week
and a half yeah depends on how much rain
you got
cool and um
those i got a hedge trimmer
i [ __ ] hate doing hedges and [ __ ]
making them little round things i'm not
a [ __ ] artist when it comes i'm not a
sculptor
yeah edward scissorhanded with scissors
[Laughter]
for scissors
yeah
your edward big meaty hands yeah
but uh yeah we gotta talk about
okay so yeah before we will talk about
the movie i promise but um
so actually we were gonna go see
halloween kills
uh this morning but then when i looked
up like to get tickets
the earliest show was like at 3 30. i'm
like uh okay
i thought yeah because i thought oh we
can go see it at like 11 or something
and then like come back and review it
but they were like nope you're not doing
that so i was like okay i guess we'll go
see it thursday or something
but yeah so uh so we went out last night
and we stayed like we stayed it's almost
closing which we don't usually and um
then we're like man we're gonna stop at
ihop and get some omelettes or something
like that like on the way home because
it's on our way back
and so we stopped and i was like it
looks kind of dark in there i was like
maybe it's not open 24 hours because i
thought it was up in 24 hours
and then so tom goes up to the door
and
they're playing music and everything
it's like rock music
the music was on yeah he walk in and
it's [ __ ] dark as [ __ ] and the music
is going on hello hello
this is
closed and their door was over and then
the door was wide open i could have gone
in there and i said jenny man i'm gonna
make something
that's not breaking and entering it's
just entering
since well they're not here i was going
to leave the money on the table i'm
going to go ahead and start cooking
funny
yeah they left that [ __ ] wide open and
it was three o'clock in the morning and
it closed at 11. yeah and it probably
and two hours to close down well it
depends on a light night maybe less than
an hour okay so they hadn't been in
there for a long time apparently they
only they are open 24 hours but only on
friday nights and saturday night yes
like only on the weekends
and um yeah so
we just assumed that they were gonna be
open and so it was just funny that he
walked in i was like oh it is open and
then i walk in i'm like what the [ __ ]
dark as hell it's like dark in there and
he's like hello music's going
i was like so that was so weird so we go
to mcdonald's and order mcdonald's
afterwards it's up the street and i told
them and they were like it's open and i
said yeah it's open did you call the
police and i was like no
we've been drinking we can't call the
cops
no he says maybe you should call him
because it's open they left it open and
said yeah the music's going and you can
walk right in just all the lights
and everything i forgot to lock the door
the door that's all forgot to lock the
door and i didn't want to get anybody in
trouble
you know what i mean well that's going
to happen anyway because then the next
shift comes in in the morning be like
what the [ __ ] why is the door open why
is the music still going yeah that's
what they're going to have
unless there was somebody in there and
they were shutting down still and they
hadn't left but there weren't any cars
that i remembered yeah there were no
cars in the lot and nobody answered you
when you said hello because they should
have said hey we're closed or something
uh maddie ps does pookie lake at the
house i'm pretty sure yeah yeah she's
super into it yeah it took her a while
to get used to the stairs because she
was just kind of like what the [ __ ] is
this all about she's laying on her back
right now she is oh she's
laying on her back her feet up in the
air
i call him her drumsticks yeah
this little little chick
because they're always like hanging like
that oh my god it's so [ __ ] funny she
and then if you look at her like while
she's doing that she's like what there's
nothing weird about this at all she's
just like lazy girls
like a weirdo
you're so weird pookie but in a good way
yeah so uh so yeah so we didn't get to
see halloween kills however
uh we did watch on shutter vhs 94
because i know a couple of you guys had
asked me about it now the vhs series of
films this is the fourth one and they're
all like they're not sequels or anything
like that obviously because they're all
just like anthologies oh my gosh sorry
it's all right
i'm so [ __ ] tired um and i think i
saw
the first one and i remember liking that
i might have seen the second one too but
then wasn't the third one vhs viral and
i feel like a lot of people didn't like
that one i'm pretty sure i didn't see
that one but i know i saw the first one
i maybe saw the second one this one
actually i think i like this one better
than the first one i liked the whole
because the other ones right they didn't
really i mean they it was just more like
a straight ahead anthology in the sense
that
i don't remember the first one having
like a wraparound story or that they
were all kind of like related or wasn't
it somebody that just like found
wasn't the first one didn't they just
like find a bunch of
vhs tapes like in someone's basement or
something am i remembering that right
it's well i'm kind of asking the chat
more than anything yeah so it's there
was kind of a wraparound i guess this
one has
sort of a wrap around and it goes like
back and forth so the wraparound story
which to which i think was the weakest
thing but it doesn't really matter
because that wasn't like the main thrust
of it i guess was that it was like this
underground lair
and
it was like i guess it was like some
kind of weird like suicide cult or
something like that and it turned out to
be like these two women and they were
making all these videos so while there
was like a drug raid like there all
these like cops and stuff or swat team
or whatever while they're in there
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] is
going on thinking that they're going
there to make like a big drug bust but
then they find like the suicide cult so
then while it's going through there like
they
show like all the videos like on the
various tvs and stuff in this cult
compound or whatever
so that's the wraparound and like i said
i didn't
i thought that was the weakest one but
honestly like the rest of them i thought
were pretty [ __ ] good like the rest
of the um yeah it was entertaining yeah
i was entertained um
and then like the first one is called
like the first segment after that is
called what was the first one called the
storm drain that was one about ratman
yeah yeah yeah yeah this now
this movie
it has its own gestalt
and something like an anthology like
creep show it's very cinematic it's very
filmish you know what i'm talking about
not this
on purpose it's the opposite it looks
real cheap in vhs yeah well the whole
series is like that that's just kind of
basically they just give the directors
they're like okay just make a segment
but it's supposed to look like an old
video tape yeah and it
kind of does you know um they kind of
age it so it's like the tracking's off
well some of them the actually a couple
of the segments i can't remember which
ones but um they did actually film it on
using equipment from 1994 and then they
took the videotape that they put it on
and taped like okay like made dupes of
it like a bunch of times so it's so it
is actually like
period accurate okay but they because
they wanted it to look like anything
even other segments don't look like that
yeah like i said not everybody went the
distance like
for varus military but um
although i'll tell you it does have a
lot of strengths uh in general you know
not not all stories are equal in this
the writing the storytelling is pretty
good it's entertaining yeah okay
um the military equipment
the weapons and the
uh
uniforms that they're wearing and
there's a couple different groups of
guys that they show over the span of the
whole movie is period accurate so i was
actually kind of impressed
even the foreign one
was period accurate for 94 95 96 right
at the time yeah wearing the right gear
the helmets the elves the the lbv's
it was cutting edge back in say 94 95
96. now that's retro as [ __ ] but they
got it right and the same thing with the
weapons they got the weapons right it
really did seem like they were committed
to making this actually look like
correct videotapes that that were in
1994 yeah i mean they did a good job i
was around in 1994. yeah and also it
does a bunch of horror movie slash
action movie tropes and styles from the
90s so
it's like something and we're not
talking about realism we're talking
about
hollywood gags from the 90s in action
flicks they do it in this too yeah and
some of the gags came from 90s video
games yeah so
each little team took the 90s seriously
they 90s they 90s the [ __ ] out out of
each story they really did they knew
what they were doing so i kind of like
so even though i think when i said
earlier that it's like that the first
one didn't have a wraparound the first
one had to wrap around but the first one
didn't i don't remember it having like a
theme kind of like but this one is
actually like the theme all of them are
set in 1994 and they're all supposed to
look like videotapes from 1994. or like
you know something you would find like
an underground type videotape in 1994 so
they really like committed
to that
premise yeah of like making but yeah so
the first one's called storm drain this
one it's good but i think this is
probably like my least favorite one um
you know other than the wrap around
which like i said there wasn't a lot to
the wrap around so you know i'm not
gonna get too upset about that but you
know this one was still funny because it
was kind of like a reporter
and they had heard i guess it was like
an urban legend going around about this
dude named rapman that like lived down
in the sewers and so she like i guess
they wanted her to go down there and
figure out what the hell was going on
and uh she goes down there and there's
like a homeless guy and she's trying to
like help him and uh things don't go the
way that you might think so that one was
um that one was pretty good and i i did
like i appreciated and i didn't even
realize when i was watching it that
this was actually another segment but it
was just like super short it was the um
the veggie masher
yeah
the commercials the commercial yeah it
was just kind of like those 90s
commercials that would ridiculous
[ __ ] [ __ ] for your kitchen
you know what maybe before
maker and weird [ __ ] you would never use
well it's fun and i remember those
because i used to record uh you know
mystery science theater off comedy
central
back in the 90s
and um and i still had those videotapes
for a really long time and it still had
all the commercials on there so it's
like it really really made me laugh like
how well they
they got that across and that veggie but
this this segment's only like a minute
long yeah but it's like this this the
funniest thing about it to me like other
than watching the machine just look
going like that like
but he's just kind of like um i can't
remember what like all the vegetables he
said but he's like you know mushrooms
peppers then he holds up a thing he's
like these
what was great about that
that made me laugh i did some time in uh
direct sales in the 90s and got a really
good [ __ ] old school training and
some of the guys that i worked with also
came from the tv
and just selling [ __ ] over you know that
way the telemarketing that's what they
called it no telemark know what they
call it it wasn't telemarketing it was
tele
uh i don't remember what what's but
anyway selling things over tv
infomercial infomercial type game
scene you know what's so funny about
that is that the demographic that they
were selling to was just
middle to old age
female overweight
lonely impulse buyers yeah and they
would sell these things to women and
with credit cards back in the
pre-internet era they were being
comforted by the
the voice of this same infomercial over
and over again they'd buy that [ __ ] and
if it was you know like the the veggie
masher yeah they would buy that yeah you
did buy that
uh but what was funny is that the buyer
would always be
a not an
untrained female cook
fantasizing about using that in the
kitchen and they would never use it
but yeah research says they'd buy the
[ __ ] they'd never use it i knew a lot of
people that bo that bought those type of
things and yeah they would never they
would take it out and go isn't that
wonderful and they put it underneath the
thing and they would underneath the
cupboard and they'd never use it again
well because it's part of the marketing
strategy
the like you said i think the whole
thing was that
everybody wants a gadget that's going to
solve all the problems and make their
life easier it's it's all it was an
emotional sale yeah yeah that's all it
was so you just kind of picture yourself
as that person that it's like oh i'm
gonna get that egg boiler doohickey and
like you know i'm gonna i'm gonna boil
all the eggs and all my problems will be
yeah
the same thing that was going on in
televangelism yeah
surprisingly enough it's the same sale
yeah it's exactly the same thing well
that's a product just like any other
product yeah they know their audience
it's a comforting product you buy it you
feel better you don't ever use it though
yeah ridiculous even though you i mean i
think people do
intend to use it yeah but then they
never really
use it there they never use it because
then when it gets there you're like wait
i have to learn how to use this yeah and
then
that's not as cool as you thought it was
right and the end result isn't as nice
or impressive and besides you're in the
house by yourself yeah so what you can
cut a radish into something that looks
like a rubber nothing gives a [ __ ]
remember that tool
the pedophore making thing and cut a
radish into a rose and take a carrot and
turn a carrot into a tulip make all this
pretty [ __ ]
these are single older women long
divorce children gone if they ever had
them or whatever nobody's there in the
trailer with them anthony
okay double wide or single wide you know
nobody's in there so they can make all
this pretty [ __ ] they want nobody sees
it so they never use the [ __ ]
well nowadays you could do it and then
take pictures of it and put it on it no
you could but this is all pre-internet
so yeah
it's a hoarder mentality yeah that's
yeah it's just kind of like something
they buy a bunch of crap and it's sad
when you think about it it is yeah it is
but you know and honestly like most of
that i've never bought any of those
products myself
but um like i said i think the only easy
kitchen thing that i ever bought was a
bread maker or somebody gave me a break
and i used the [ __ ] out of that well
some things are practical yeah but if
you look at home shopping network and
all those other [ __ ] things that they
were trinkets
they did and they they did one thing
basically one thing and they sell you
four things that all did one thing but
it was all really impractical [ __ ] yeah
it was it was like something you would
never ever need need
turning radishes into [ __ ] roses yeah
it's like how often do you have a call
for that you're right i can't think of a
single time you're a single woman
there's nobody
you're a single woman beyond your dating
years and nobody's there to see that
[ __ ] and even if and even if you did
have a date come over they would not
give a [ __ ] about a rat a shaved like a
rose like a guarantee right there
and you're like nah i don't want to
[ __ ] eat in this damn [ __ ] hole
before
you know rats nest everything let's go
let's go to denny's
that's where they're her perkins yeah
let's go down to perkins get that
cracker barrel get that big fat yeast
roll yeah did they still have those i
don't even know if perkins is around
anymore that's just something i remember
when i was a kid yeah okay
that's too much of a side track we got
to get back over well it was kind of
related it was really
it was just related to the shortest
segment of the whole movie just because
that i just think it's funny that
[ __ ] home shopping network made a
whole career out of doing that well [ __ ]
man one used this trinket after another
ubc is still around yeah middle-aged
women with [ __ ] credit cards
and it's like everybody's all they don't
have the internet so they just buy this
the best thing thank you david june i
want a carrot that looks like a rose
yeah
and carrots look like tulips
[Laughter]
all right i want a tool that turns all
the vegetables like into looking like
penises that would be yeah
i bet some like there's got some kind of
dirty qvc make all your vegetarians
pretend to be carnivorous
that's what i mean eat that meat baby
that's what you should call it you
should call it eat that meat baby
i send that [ __ ] i'll make a box i'll
send that [ __ ]
the only meat you're getting right there
that's just cucumbers yeah it's like a
cucumber
uncircumcised
oh
billy
god
yeah
no what i was gonna say is my favorite
thing i think everybody's favorite thing
about those um
about those um
infomercials was i love uh how they
would have the people on there that
didn't know how to do like the most
simple everyday tasks it's like has this
ever happened to you have you ever been
like walking down the street like a
normal person then they have somebody
going what
like look i even knocked my own glasses
off and it's just kind of like well we
can solve that problem now here's the
thing that walks for you because you're
a [ __ ] the king of all that [ __ ] was
life alert
falling and i can't get up yeah remember
the little people still remember that
[ __ ] i still remember that [ __ ] they're
totally obsolete totally absolutely well
yeah you don't need that or no cell
phone back then it's like back then that
seemed like a like an okay idea didn't
get to the phone cause i'm like oh my
god grandma fell off the [ __ ] bridge
grandma fell off the lead grandma
my grandfather used to call it the yeah
old people don't have a gun
i'm like there's no t in that word
oh my god
all right
so um
uh danny rolling ghostface said vhs3 was
the worst out of the series that's what
i've heard uh that was vhs viral right
um and i haven't seen that one and he
said two was my favorite out of the
series i can't remember if i saw two or
not i know i saw one but uh i don't know
i liked this one a lot yeah it's not bad
yeah okay so um then the next story was
actually i don't know i don't know i
don't know if i want to say this is my
favorite one this one might be my
favorite one the frankenstein's no the
uh the empty wake the one about the
woman at the um oh the funeral was like
i really liked that one i liked that one
because i love [ __ ] about like creepy
funerals and i just thought it was
really well done like the way the
tension was like but because she's like
supposed to be filming awake
and there's a dude in the coffin and
everything obviously but like nobody
shows up and she's getting like really
creeped out and then like she think
keeps thinking she hears like noises
from inside the coffin yeah and i really
really liked the special effects like
the reveal on this one like i thought
that it's not super gory but i really
liked the way the the corpse looked good
the best one of course was the foreign
one about the damn mad scientist that
one was the craziest and the goriest and
yeah i i can see that's i mean that's
what it's it's it's hard to say because
that one was awesome too it was kind of
like frankenstein's army rose it was
kind of like that i think it was
indonesian i want to say it was
indonesian or at least like it took
place in jakarta like i think they
mentioned it but yeah that was it was
basically like a mad scientist and he
was trying to make
he was kidnapping people and he was
making like cyborgs yeah battle bot
cyborgs yeah and it's like and that one
was that one was great because it was
just like [ __ ] super gory man yeah
there's a bunch of shout outs to like
doom
like doom 2 yeah
shout outs like duke nukem there's a
bunch of video games [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah it's like let's see what that noise
is but uh yeah the thing about it is
that
i like that one because one of the uh
cyborgs that the dude created
uh and you don't see her until the end
but i guess he like puts a camera like
into her face or something like that
and so
for most of the segment you're seeing
things from her point of view so it's
almost kind of like a first person
shooter like video game um
and yeah they really captured that
aesthetic really well like when he was
saying about doom and everything like
that that's a lot what it looked like
and like i said it was just so it was
just over the top gory and super super
fun um she was like heads and arms and
[ __ ] flying everywhere people exploding
it was just [ __ ] great like you know
people being guess what that was what
garage door going up on its own whoo
are you starting with your poltergeist
[ __ ] at this house too there's a garage
door going up i thought it sounded like
the garage door yeah maybe somebody's
got a garage door open or something the
clicker thing that yeah that's on the
same frame that's
yeah i didn't think that it happened
like so far
but yeah so that but um yeah that one
was called the subject like i was saying
that um i was saying while you were gone
yeah was that uh the reason i think that
one kind of came across like a first
person shooter is because the cyborg
character like you're seeing things from
her point of view and she's and she has
a camera like in her face or whatever
yeah or he may he replaced her head with
a camera or something like that um yeah
so that yeah that was really good i
think it was indonesian um yeah so that
was like the only quote-unquote foreign
uh one and that was the goriest
and then um
and then oh this one was good too uh the
next one was called terror and that was
like a group of like militia guys like
in detroit
and they were planning to like blow up i
guess they were supposed to be like
timothy mcveigh type [ __ ] yeah
and um they were planning to blow up
this building
and i i don't want to spoil like what
they were going to use
to blow the building up
because
you'll i mean you'll figure it out
before the end
but
because i figured it out probably like 5
or 10 minutes in because i was just kind
of like wait that is that what's with
that guy like you know there it goes
again
where the [ __ ]
it's gotta be somebody's gotta have a
clicker around here that's the same as
ours yeah cause that's like really
[ __ ] spooky
it's just to keep hearing the garage
door going up and down oh my god but uh
but yeah
so yeah that was like it's kind of like
yeah it was a bunch of militia guys and
they were gonna blow up a federal
building and they were all like um
they were all like fundamental as
christians i think too but they all kind
of lived out in the [ __ ] this
compound
and
they um
like i said man i just really wouldn't
want to spoil it but um
they had like a really interesting
uh explosive that they were gonna use
and uh you'll find out what it is if you
watch it but that one was also fun like
really really violent lots of people
getting like shot and close up lots of
people exploding
um you know heads
being ripped off and stuff like that so
that was also a good one um
and i have to say too that the whole
i turned it off oh okay it's got to be
somebody around here yeah that's yeah
that's pretty weird yeah um
yeah but i was gonna say that a lot of
it's
a lot of the um special effects in this
especially like the real close-up like
head shots and stuff like that looks
really good yeah i mean
i they really like i said they really
committed to making everything look like
a [ __ ] up like snuff film or something
like that for like from 1994. i mean i
think they did a really good job with
that and all the special effects like a
lot of them look really real i don't
even think
i
even in the one with all the cyborgs
that didn't look like cgi
i mean
was it it didn't look like cgi to me
what are you doing
she's not the ghost she's just so busy
hey she's mad at the ghost look i do
that [ __ ] and her ears go back [ __ ] you
yeah she's like no i'm busy she's still
tearing i'm just chasing the books
she's like
yeah did you [ __ ] over spock did you
[ __ ] over merrick spock she did she
knocked him over yeah she loves on spock
though she goes up to his leg and like
rubs her head yeah and like somebody's
like knock someone she loves spock's
wedding i'm gonna do it again huh she's
like yeah
[Laughter]
she knows and then as soon as tom got up
she's like oh [ __ ] yeah i'm in trouble
she's trying to play a little game
yeah then she goes right back over there
she's incorrigible yeah seriously
she can't but i mean you can't be mad at
her she's too [ __ ] cute it's all
funny gangster it is
but yeah so like i said i can't i can't
spoil what the what the explosive is but
you'll figure it out if you watch it but
yeah that was also a really good one so
like i said other than
the wrap around which was okay um
and the the first one like the storm
drain one about rapman which actually
had its moments also um all those
segments were pretty [ __ ] solid i
thought i was like pretty entertained
you know and like i said i really like
that they
um that they kind of had a
theme throughout the whole thing and
it's like all of them are 1994 all of
them look like
something that you would videotape back
then and i like to because this is
something that happens with a lot of
found footage [ __ ] um and i think i
brought this up before
is that
in a lot of found footage movies
you can't it's hard to suspend your
disbelief because after some point
you'll be like look no [ __ ] in
their right mind would still be filming
this [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
that's the problem and um yeah and so
it's kind of hard because you know and
even ones i really like i'd just be like
come on now wouldn't have somebody have
just been like [ __ ] this camera and like
i'm not filming this
very artificial and contrived to me it
is i mean it is obviously because
they're making a movie um but i but i
like this too because this
i can't really think of anything in here
that took me out of it in the sense that
you know nobody would be filming this
like nobody would have a reason to be
filming this
um every single one of them seemed to
have a really solid
um
you know kind of motivation for somebody
to be filming it you know what i mean
and for somebody to continue filming it
so i was never taken out of it like okay
nobody would be filming in after this
point so again props there because you
got to be real creative
in found footage like why anybody would
still be filming this [ __ ]
because you would have dropped the
camera if the monster was coming to get
you
i'm not filming it oh go oh it's eating
my leg you know what i mean what the
[ __ ] nobody would do that but uh yeah so
that i think that the one with the um
with the militia was the last one and
then they do
like the the closing segment of uh the
the wrap around which i think is called
holy hell
um and they kind of like reveal what all
these tapes were and stuff like that but
yeah like i said pretty solid and i'm
not a huge fan of found footage which i
think i've mentioned before even though
you know i've seen a lot of good ones
but it's not kind of my go-to genre so
i wasn't actually gonna i mean i was
gonna watch this but eventually but then
i thought wait i'm kind of in the mood
for this and i liked the first one um
i think i liked this one better i just
thought it held together better
i mean
the first one was good but i don't
really remember a lot of the segments
from it
um
but i don't know i just i i thought this
one was like pretty solid now i'm gonna
have to see the third one because
everyone says it's bad yeah okay but
i'll leave that one to you this isn't
really my thing i don't like found
footage that much and this is about all
i can tolerate
yeah i mean like if it gets any worse
than that then i'm not gonna [ __ ] with
it well i guess what is she doing um
this is just an ongoing quest to tear
those damn books out of that corner and
it's just those ones she thinks there's
something back there
i don't know
maybe that gecko would disappeared yeah
see okay so the other day
she was like losing her [ __ ] in here and
i was like is this [ __ ] haunted you can
tell me it's like are you look cause she
kept looking in the closet like really
intently yeah and i'm like there's
nothing there poop it's like what's the
matter with you there was something
there there was something there it was a
tiny tiny baby gecko about that leg he
came he actually like crawled out later
and i was like aha yeah that's what she
could she heard that [ __ ] yeah and she
or she she saw him right and it's like
once she sees a bug or a lizard or
something like that in the house she
does not forget it she does not let it
go you can like because a lot of times a
lizard would get in the old house and
she'd be looking right out and be like
look look look and we'd be like oh my
god and then tom would like pick it up
and take it outside like rescue it and
then for the next couple hours she'd
still be like sniffing around that same
spot where the [ __ ] is where is he yeah
she didn't have this eye she didn't have
a concept of hands yeah and pick things
up and take it and take them home she'll
still be looking at the same spot where
to go
yeah she just keeps like running around
with her little tail going like that
like where is he he was right here they
don't process they don't process images
the same way
the human mind does they they don't see
shapes that well and they don't really
see colors that well they just see
motion
and my hand coming down she sees that
moving but the the idea that the or the
the concept that the hand took
the lizard away is kind of they don't
really see it i don't think they see
that part happening they just go it
vanished where is it
you know and it's not moving if it's not
moving a lot of times they can't see it
yeah so they still think it's there but
camouflaged well and they can probably
still smell it too because cats have a
really good sense of smell which i think
a lot of people don't know i think
everybody's talking about like how good
dog sense of smell is i think cat sense
of smell is better but she'll she'll
chase a lizard then the lizard will stop
moving and she'll continue to look
around for it because it's stopped
moving she can't see it when it's not
moving
yeah which is the second it moves she
goes there it is
there you are you [ __ ] i
couldn't see you're standing still
process moving things very well but not
things are still i wonder if lizards
have figured that out it's like i just
have to be really stupid they do a lot
of things yeah they do a lot yeah i
think most predators like that they see
them the way their eyes and their brains
work the the motion is primary over the
shape so i guess any animal that's like
a prey animal has probably learned every
time it's just like freeze yeah and it's
and if you're already camouflaged
you can kind of blend in and a predator
will continue moving kind of got a kind
of movie to predator yeah cover yourself
with the mud
well because he had heat vision yeah now
she's over there sitting by
she's and also she's been sitting on top
of the toilet i don't really get what
that's about either and i bought her a
new
litter box yeah and i put it all in
there and she just will not use she goes
in there and plays in it yeah but she's
going back
okay um
let's go ahead and cut it short i think
yeah because i finished it because i'm
like super sleepy yeah and i have to
finish watching all those
hammer house of horror episodes i think
i still have like five of them left well
we can watch some together later but i
was like we we don't have time to like
both watch all of them because
they're they're too long because there's
i didn't realize it was 13 episodes and
each episode is an hour
so
i watched like three or four of them the
first night and then i've been watching
them today but i'm trying to like stay
awake because i'm like still really
tired from last night
wow it was like so sleepy but we just
had to tell you guys about the [ __ ]
ihops
that was so [ __ ] weird yeah it was
weird yeah we were just like that we
could just walk in i was like oh my god
we could have stole all kinds of [ __ ]
there was nothing in here there was
nothing in there today i wouldn't do
that anyway it's just food i wouldn't do
that anyway but i just i said how funny
would it be if you just
if the cops came and you're just in
there like making some pancakes or
something it's like what now what was
here
what did i expect me to do make my own
food [ __ ] all right so uh
anyway we will be back tomorrow night
and remember tomorrow night is the main
show now
and i'm very excited because finally
finally i've been wanting to do this
show for a long time and finally at one
in the patreon poll we were talking
about
mary shelley and the haunted summer like
where she got the idea for frankenstein
that whole situation which
may if you don't know anything about it
it may not sound that interesting but
it's actually it's really interesting
so interesting that they made a couple
movies about it um
one of which was directed by ken russell
actually uh it's called gothic but yeah
so we're gonna be talking about that
tomorrow night that should be a fun one
uh so yeah so thanks for dropping by and
hanging out with us this afternoon it
feels like sunday i guess because we
went out last night i keep forgetting
it's tuesday it's so weird um but yeah
so
we're gonna do the show tomorrow night
at 5 00 pm
so come on by and talk about
frankenstein and [ __ ] with us so we'll
see you guys then
bye